je voudrais qu'on fasse équipe comme
batman et robin personne n'ait envie
d'avoir le rôle de robin c'est cool
d'être robin tu étais bien le robin de
big daddy
robin rêverait d'être match j'essaie de
te dire c'est qu'on devrait faire équipe
toi et moi comme le dynamique duo je
joue en première division toi tu es
encore chez les poussins à leur
entraînement
je veux être à la hauteur et tu es ce
que je connais qui ressemble plus à un
vrai super héros dans as pas marre de
bosser tout seul t'as pas envie de
pouvoir compter sur quelqu'un d'avoir
quelqu'un qui te couvrirai
oh
et tu feras tout ce que je te dirai à la
lettre à la lettre
tannis ma gamine de 15 ans c'est quoi
ces conneries tu fais taper tasse je te
frappe comme une [ __ ] plus